IMPLODE.
BUT THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE
ANGLE.
TEN WEEKS AFTER THE DUFFEL OF
GEORGE FLOYD DURING AN ATTEMPTED
ARREST A FEW MILES FROM HERE, WE
CAME HERE TO ASSESS THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND.
BECAUSE THE RIOTS THAT LEFT
BEHIND BLOCK AFTER BLOCK OF
DESTRUCTION LEFT PEOPLE IN THEIR
WAKE.
AND TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO
BRING YOU THE NEVER TOLD STORIES
OF THOSE BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
WERE ABANDONED BY THE
POLITICIANS AND THE POLICE.
HOW MUCH OF WHAT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE AND HEAR TONIGHT IS
EXTREMELY DISTURBING.
AND IT BEGS FOR POLITICAL
CHANGE.
>> ELECTED TO OFFICIALS SHOULD B
FOCUSED ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
WITHOUT IT, THIS ECOSYSTEM
DOESN’T WORK.
>> WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR
RESPONSE FROM OUR OFFICIALS,
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD ANY WORD FROM
THEM.
OUR DREAMS HAVE BEEN SHATTERED.
>> I CAN SENSE IT’S NOT JUST
ABOUT YOU, IT’S ABOUT THIS.
IT’S ABOUT A FORMERLY VIBRANT
COMMUNITY.
>> YEAH.
>> THE SCENE HERE NOW IS...
ALL OF THE EMOTION COMES BACK.
ALL OF THE SADNESS AND ANGER
KIND OF JUST FLOWS BACK THROUGH.
>> Laura: NOW MORE OF THESE
RIVETING STORIES OF RUIN AND
HOPE LATER ON IN THE SHOW.
NOW AS WE WALKED TO EAST
LAKE STREET TODAY, I KEPT
THINKING ABOUT HOW SO MANY OF
THE GOOD PEOPLE THERE -- THEY
JUST CAN’T GET A BREAK.
THEIR VOTES HAVE BEEN TAKING FOR
GRANTED FOR DECADES.
AND WHEN THEY NEEDED SAFETY
MOST, THE POLITICAL LEADERS WERE
NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
NOW WHEN THE GOVERNOR FINALLY
MOBILIZED AND ACCEPTED FEDERAL
HELP, IT WAS TOO LATE FOR MANY
PEOPLE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD.
CRIMINALS AND RIOTERS?
THEY WERE ABLE TO FLATTEN
LIVELIHOODS AND TERRORIZE THOSE
WHO DESERVE SAFETY AND PEACE OF
MIND.
NOW HERE IN MINNEAPOLIS, LET’S
USE THE TRAGIC DEATH OF MR.
MR. FLOYD FOR THE DEVASTATION.
AND OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS,
AND PORTLAND, THEY BLAME THE
VIOLENCE ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT WAS JUST AS PATHETIC.
>> THE WHOLE PRESENCE IS JUST
HAS THE OPPOSITE EFFECT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING
TROUBLE.
WE KNOW WHAT TODAY’S.
THIS PERVERSE, PANDERING TO
WHITE AMERICANS.
>> TRUMP CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON
AND PERHAPS EVEN FUELED THE
ALREADY VOLATILE SITUATION
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PROTESTERS.
>> Laura: BUT NOW WE SEE THAT
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
MORE CHAOS OCCURRED OVER THE
WEEKEND.
DAYS AFTER THE FEDERAL PRESENCE
RETREATED.
MAYOR TED WHEELER SHOULD
APOLOGIZE AND THEN RESIGN.
BUT HE WON’T.
HE DID HOWEVER FINALLY HAVE TO
ADMIT IT’S NOT A PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
>> WHEN YOU COMMIT ARSON WITH AN
EXCEL EVENT IN AN ATTEMPT TO
BURN DOWN THE BUILDING THAT IS
OCCUPIED BY PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE
INTENTIONALLY TRAPPED INSIDE,
YOU ARE NOT DEMONSTRATING.
YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO COMMIT
MURDER.
WE ANTICIPATE ADDITIONAL ATTACKS
OVER THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
I CANNOT, AND I WILL NOT,
TOLERATE THAT.
>> Laura: NOW I THINK
CHICAGO’S LOOTERS FELT LEFT OUT
OF THE FUN.
THEY WENT WILD LAST NIGHT TAKING
ALL OF THE ACTION TO DOWNTOWN TO
THE SAME MAGNIFICENT MILE
SHOPPING DISTRICT.
IT WAS ALSO BRAZEN THAT THEY
DROVE UP TO LUXURY STORES AND
LOADED UP ON MERCHANDISE.
BUT THE POLICE WERE TOO
OVERWHELMED TO STOP ALL OF THEM.
NOW LET’S REMEMBER, THIS IS
HAPPENING.
NOT BECAUSE OF GEORGE FLOYD, NOT
HAPPENING BECAUSE OF POLICE
BRUTALITY OR SOME ALTERCATION
EARLIER IN THE AFTERNOON.
THIS IS HAPPENING BECAUSE OF 50
YEARS OF TERRIBLE LEADERSHIP IN
THESE CITIES, A BREAKDOWN IN THE
FAMILY, LACK OF FATHER FIGURES,
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IT IS CULMINATING IN A SUMMER OF
INOCULATIONANNIHILATION.
YOU CAN DESTROY PROPERTY, YOU
CAN GET AWAY WITH IT.
YOU CAN STEAL FROM STORES IN
BROAD DAYLIGHT AND GET AWAY WITH
IT.
YOU CAN BRUTALLY BEAT AND ASSENT
BY STANDARDS, AND YOU WILL GET
AWAY WITH IT.
AND OF COURSE, YOU CAN MARCH BY
THE THOUSANDS WITH ZERO SOCIAL
DISTANCING DURING A PANDEMIC AND
GET AWAY WITH IT.
NOW FOR MONTHS, OFFICIALS AND
THE MEDIA -- THEY ALTERNATIVELY
TOLERATED ALL OF THIS.
WHILE HASSLING THE REST OF US
FOR WANTING US TO HAVE OUR KIDS
GO TO SCHOOL OR HAVE COLLEGE
FOOTBALL OR TO HAVE AN OUTDOOR
PICNIC.
WHICH IS WHAT MAYOR LORI
LIGHTFOOT WAS FOCUSED ON JUST
HOURS BEFORE THE CHAOS IN
DOWNTOWN.
IT’S CALLED A PANDEMIC PEOPLE,
SHE TWEETED.
THIS RECKLESS BEHAVIOR ON THE
BEACH IS WHAT WILL CAUSE US TO
SHUT DOWN THE PARKS AND LATE
FRONT.
RECKLESS BEHAVIOR?
WHAT’S RECKLESS IS YOUR
LEADERSHIP.
ALONG WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF SO
MANY OF YOUR DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE NATION.
SHE IS HASSLING TAXPAYING
CITIZENS FOR OUT ENJOYING THE
SUNSHINE, MEANWHILE PRESIDED OVE
HORRIFIC JULY.
HOMICIDES UP 139% COMPARED TO
LAST YEAR.
AT LEAST 107 PEOPLE MURDERED AND
573 SHOT INCLUDING 58 MINORS.
NOW, IF THAT WAS HAPPENING JUST
LIKE MAYOR WHEELER,
MAYOR LIGHTFOOT HAS BEEN BLAMING
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR HER CITY’S
PROBLEMS.
TO SPEAK OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OBVIOUSLY THINKS
THAT THEY WILL SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS BY TRYING TO DEMONIZE AND
DEMOCRATS, PARTICULARLY
WOMEN MAYORS, BECAUSE IT WILL
SCORE POINTS.
GOOD LUCK.
THE MAYORS ARE GETTING IT DONE.
TO PROTECT RESIDENTS OF THE
CITY, WHETHER OR NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF HER STEPS UP NOT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GETTING IT
DONE ALL RIGHT.
IF YOUR VERSION OF GETTING IT
DONE IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEN FOR THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS.
BY THE WAY, CAVING TO THE
TEACHERS UNION, DID YOU CHECK
THAT OUT?
THEY ARE SHUTTING DOWN SCHOOLS
FOR IN PERSON LEARNING.
IT WILL ALL BE ONLINE.
THAT’S GOING TO BE GREAT FOR THE
KIDS.
ANOTHER CHICAGO DISASTER.
BUT THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
NO MATTER HOW RICH AND
SUCCESSFUL CITY IS, OR A
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THE CITY IS, IT
CAN’T BE SAVED FROM PORT PORT
DEMOCRAT LEADERSHIP.
THEY WILL CRY RACISM TO AVOID
ANY ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THEIR OWN
FAILURES.
AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TIME TO
CLEAN UP THE MESS, EVERYTHING
LEFT BEHIND, THEY ARE NOWHERE TO
BE FOUND.
AFTER THE DUST SETTLES, THEY
WILL STILL EXPECT MINORITIES,
THOSE HURT MOST BY THEIR
GOD-AWFUL POLICIES, TO VOTE FOR
THEM WITHOUT QUESTION.
OTHERWISE, REMEMBER AS JOE BIDEN
SAID "YOU AIN’T BLACK."
IF THE DEMOCRATS WIN, THE
LOOTERS WILL KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
FREE REIGN TO ATTACK NOT JUST
EVERY CITY AND TOWN IN THE
COUNTRY, BUT THE SUBURBS AS WELL